as i was growing the business i was
deciding if i wanted to expand the
business into phoenix arizona by the
arizona market or go to detroit and me
and my co-founder at the time we went
back and forth and you know phoenix
seemed like it was a lot easier because
a little further along but he had
already had some roots there of working
you know under the caregiver model and
he was like you know we talked about we
said we got to go to detroit just
because there's more black people there
like we could have a bigger impact if we
saying that we want to help and we did
that went there you know found a really
really ugly building in order to get us
operational you know they made us repave
our property they made us do so many
things just for us to get permitted
to operate we get through that process
we build it out put all our lights and
equipment everything in there and
literally after our first harvest
um i'm sitting here i'm here in
california
and my aunt calls me and she's like
we're getting robbed
and i'm like what she's like we're about
to get robbed she's like all these guys
are running up to the building and they
got guns drawn and all this thing and
i'm like what she's like yeah so i was
like auntie i was like oh yeah i gotta
you know y'all know what to do go lock
yourself in the back blah blah blah blah
and she i'm on the phone the whole time
me and my founder and she says oh no
it's the police
so i was like all right well perfect i
was like thank god i was like well get
all the paperwork go to the door blah
blah blah blah and i'm watching on
camera and all i see is
you know they all get there i see the
paddy wagon van come around guns drawing
they knocking on trying to knock the
door in and she opens the door and she
has the paperwork and literally they
just put a gun in her face and i just
see the paperwork fall i see one of the
cops pick up the paper we had like a
fridge sitting outside i think that my
guess was moving it out or whatever he
opens up the fridge take the paperwork
and throws it in there and closes it
pushes her back so she goes back into
the warehouse and they all start running
in 30 seconds later the light the
cameras are cut
they cut the cameras
process for me was very scary i'm
thinking like what did we do wrong did
the police come or did the feds come
the feds are usually going to come they
got some [ __ ] if it's the police they
probably are messed up i didn't know for
i didn't know for like 10 hours
our attorney gets there they put him in
handcuffs they didn't care and you know
at the end of the day what they were
there for was something called acid
forfeiture and what that means is if
you're found of any wrongdoing at all
any at all they confiscate everything
and they get to keep it so if there's a
million dollars in the building if
there's five luxury cars on the property
whatever they get to keep all of it if
you're found for doing any wrongdoing
six employees that was there they all
did uh jail they were in jail for four
days which is the max amount of time you
can be there without being charged they
couldn't find anything to charge them
for for the four days but they made them
stay the entire four days it was really
emotional for them like honestly man um
they're all still very traumatized
behind that
episode like if you talk to my aunt
about it uh and you know when our
growers they'll break down crying every
time they can't even have a conversation
about it without
crying you know what i'm saying it
brings them back to a very dark place
that obviously it just wasn't cool so we
went through the process had to get each
one of them they're all attorneys and
long story short went in court and they
threw it out and they said they had no
business rating us you know not only did
we have
um authorization from the city we
authorization from the state which
nobody in the state had at that time we
were the only ones in the state that had
that authorization to cultivate at that
facility they took us out of business
for over three years
you know and at the end of the day
i thought about kind of packing up and
leaving but i just felt like i didn't
want to give up on the people that you
know that we were starting to help and
that we were creating relationships with
but you know that raid easily cost us
over 30 million dollars in losses you
know as a company and when you think
about you know what we've been able to
do what 30 million dollars would have
what could do for my company today you
know what i'm saying like we'd be bigger
than what people think we are now if we
had that money you know what i'm saying
so
it really sucked but you know it opened
my eyes to what everybody's been dealing
with in the industry and when i think
about like if we didn't have the
resources that we had think about the
person that averaged jonathan don't have
any of that you know one they probably
lost all their stuff they wouldn't have
had no money to fight in court
you understand what i'm saying they
wouldn't be able to pay their rent they
wouldn't have been able to keep the
lights on they wanted to keep the pay
employees keep them there until they
were able to fix things there needs to
be more accountability from government
in those type of situations because
for the local police to come in
and just
take away that opportunity is just crazy
with no recourse but no
no accountability at all so that's
something that definitely has to be
addressed
you